do you guys clean your ears as well
often because I know you're not mad too
because you went to the ear cleaning
clinic right did you feel did you feel
good afterwards no I didn't like it I
did not like it at all I thought it was
disgusting I actually do it like once
every couple weeks just because like I I
don't know why maybe it's genetics or
whatever but like I my ears produce a
[__] load of wax and if it gets left
then it sometimes I've had just like
straight up Ear blockages before because
of the wax build up so ever since I was
a kid like my mom used to like do that
whole anime thing of like I would like
like and she would clean it out yeah I
don't know you know I go when I go
shower I just soap up you know get
around this area get in there a little
bit but I'm you know I never put my
don't go deep in yeah no no like if my
if like you know I just do like that
like kind of thing right I'm like all
right that's enough like I wouldn't I
don't for most people that's enough yeah
yeah like I don't know I don't put a
[__] like a bidet inside my [__]
hey why would I do it in my ears you
know what I mean
like you know what I mean I don't I'm
just doing the rim yeah
bro like dude I don't know if you don't
want to push it in there I don't know if
it's because my mum also did the air
cleaning thing ever since I was like I
feel it's an Asian thing it must be an
Asian thing well like because I've heard
from like a million different places but
you should you know shouldn't use cotton
buds to like clean your eyes on the
goddamn package yeah it's what it says
on the goddamn packaging and you know
doctors ear doctors Health experts
obviously know what they're talking
about but God [__] damn it sometimes
there is just an itch in there that I
just can't clear our edges in your head
though
[Music]
if I don't clean my ear for about like
four days or something it's definitely
it's like comments it comes and uh it's
it's impossible to like get rid of I've
tried like other methods because because
I've read something like the popping
technique I don't do that what the [__]
is this sometimes like if I really want
to like you know get rid of that itching
deep in my ear yeah it can't be bothered
to like you know grab the thing to like
go in there I just like kind of pop it
like this yeah and it like it kind of
helps uh it's probably just Placebo it's
all in my head apparently yeah this is
all in your head I don't think they can
there's actually an itch in your ear I
think you're you're dreaming of it but I
understand what is an edge no yeah I
mean what isn't it resource music what
is what is even a match I'm itchy or am
I yeah yeah we're not like I sometimes
like I I try you know just what what
they what they record what doctors
recommend is that you need ear wax so
you should just like rinse it out and
just get the towel I like rinse like you
know just like yeah just clean it yo
that that itch that itches there and I I
cannot get rid of it we'll talk about
having an itch in there now so now I'm
feeling like there's gonna be an itch
because you keep talking about it did
you but did you ever have like problems
with your ears when you were a kid no
because I used to get ear infections all
the time when I was a kid oh really yeah
yeah I've had multiple ear infections uh
in the past so I think that's just like
kind of [__] up the inside of my ears
for the most part yeah and also I have
like very light tinnitus as well enough
if I'm going to too many concerts so
that probably doesn't help I've never
really gotten sick ever really like it's
like an infection ear infection isn't
really like ear infection is weird
because I've already had like one ear
infection once my life as a kid and uh
because like it's an ear infection
that's where your balance sensors are as
well and it was just so weird not being
able to walk yeah you know and just it
feels like you're dizzy all the time
yeah yeah yeah like you you you stand up
and you're like I don't know if I'm up
or down right now and it was it's I've
never experienced anything like that in
my life where I I literally felt like
standing up felt like I was hanging
upside down it's it's super super
[__] weird but I like I got my um I
got my ears checked when I was in
Thailand because I was like I I don't
know if watching all of these videos
like made me a bit paranoid because I'd
heard if you'd like try cleaning it with
cotton uh like earbuds like cotton buds
that you like push the wax in I was like
I want to make sure I'm not doing that
um and yeah I got it checked and
apparently it's like I I'm hoping this
wasn't the edge right because they
looked my ear and I don't know if like
when when you got your inner ears
cleaned right that was obviously like
did they take anything out of your ear
or do they just check it out
I do not feel comfortable having an
object that deeply into my ears he went
so [__] deep in my ear yeah I mean I
like basically was on the like the
moment he took it like the [__] out of
my ears went to the toilet I was like on
the toilet like like vomiting I was like
this [__] is so gross this is horrible
it's a horrible experience like I've
nearly fainted from it because I was
like oh really yeah yeah it was really
bad yeah I did not like it at all yeah
there was like a single piece of uh like
a single strand of hair just stuck in my
inner ear as they were like cleaning it
out and I was just yeah I just I'll just
never forget the feeling of just like uh
like the ear doctor was like okay
whatever you do do not move and I was
like what are you gonna do and she was
like I think I see a single single
strand of hair and I was like okay cool
she's gonna she's gonna like she's she's
just gonna clean my it's just a single
strand of hair
um she sticks she sticks like whatever
she sticks and I think it's like
tweezers or something and I'd never felt
something enter pierce my ears so deeply
that I could hear like every little
movement of the strand of hair and you
it's it's like everything is like bass
boosted that's that's kind of that's
that's that's kind of what it feels like
how are you not laughing
honestly you tickled a lot I was I it
took it took everything it had in me
just to sit still but holy [__] it was
so oh it felt so like yeah it is getting
like a splinter I do I don't know how
long that air that was like stuck in my
ear maybe that's why my ears were like
constantly see but now the question is
how the [__] did it get in there in the
first place
be like it's a [__] hole in your body
man it could could be any reason I uh I
remember when I was a kid uh my my uh
one of my physics teacher came in one
day and he was like yeah I just got a
[__] uh I got a [__] moth vacuumed
out my ear I was like I was like what oh
[__] I've had that as well actually wait
are you serious but it wasn't a moth it
was a mosquito oh [__] yeah like oh [__]
like it was a mosquito that uh like
because you know Australian summer [__]
a lot of mosquitoes especially if you're
outside and I remember yeah [__] you
just reminded me so like I had this
mosquito where like there was a mosquito
buzzing around near my ear and I think I
must have like killed it close to my ear
enough that the dead mosquito went into
my ear yeah and I didn't feel it for the
longest time and then down the road I
was like oh man it feels like
something's like blocked in my ear
so when I went to the doctor yeah the
doctor looked in she's like yeah there's
definitely [__] something in there
and she pulled out like a dead mosquito
oh and I was like and I was like Ah
that's probably what it was
like that's what I mean if you swallow
10 spiders in your sleep yeah right ten
spiders get in your ear yeah
God yeah that was top 10 reasons why
mosquitoes are [__] [__] why did
they do that thing when you're like
sleeping and they just like they it's
always the ear yeah like you you can
hear you can hear a mosquito just
buzzing around them every soft it will
just come right by your ear I don't
think I've ever been bitten by a
mosquito
you've never been to my mosquitoes maybe
you're just not aware of it
I've never seen like a like a bite on my
body from anything you also rarely go to
countries where mosquitoes that's true
like we don't have them in the UK yeah
mosquitoes
whenever we're out together you're like
I'm getting bit bitten by mosquitoes yes
because I'm I'm tanking it all for you
yeah and I'm like I'm like really I
never get bitten by anything ever like
I've I've noticed even like I I don't
know what it is something about my blood
maybe it's like my blood type
um but like in Thailand he has a
mosquito aggro skill oh no yeah over
here I have mosquito aggro so like every
time we go to Thailand uh even if a mate
like normally gets bitten by mosquitoes
as soon as we hang out together they
just never get bitten because I I like
tank all the mosquito bites for them
boys like some people as well they get
bit but some people's skin doesn't react
to being bit and other people's diet
yeah it's same same with bed bugs as
well yeah yeah like some people get the
red bumps some people don't yeah
um
I used to get them really bad well bed
bugs no no mosquito bites like I I had
maybe it's because of the mosquitoes in
Australia just op but like I I used to
have days where like I don't even feel
the bite I might be like outside on my
in my backyard just like doing something
during the night and then the next
morning I'm like what the [__] is this
giant red pack I wonder if they can tell
my blood is [__]
I don't know if that's why that's a good
thing they they land and they sniff and
they're like no this [__]
yeah because I must have like [__]
sugar sweet blood or something because
the right concoction of vitamins and
yeah because like I I've been told when
I was a kid I was because like you live
abroad so that's that's why you get
better than a lot and like the order of
grown up the more I just realized not
even if there's a foreigner next to me
uh it doesn't make a difference I'm
still the only one getting [__] bit
it doesn't matter how long I live in
Thailand I still get like the same
amount of bites I think it's got to do
with like a number of things like your
blood type is one thing but also like
how high your blood sugar is and like
just oh all that kind of stuff just
thrown together because in Japan it's
like oh if you have uh orgata like oh
blood type uh you're more likely to get
bitten by mosquitoes